ladies and gentlemen welcome to
Stockholm for the eleventh edition of
the FTTH conference showcasing a
brighter future
Lisa Sven he's in charge of the R&D
department of a large multinational
company and he just spent the whole
afternoon in a stressful meeting with
his main research lab in Japan
Sven is a workaholics but thanks to
videoconferencing he does not travel as
much as he used to and cloud computing
allows him to often work from home
because ven loves to spend time with his
family
look at him he's just picked up his son
Bjorn from hockey training this is Bjorn
apart from teasing his sister his
favorite hobby is online gaming and he
always wins because with Fiverr he's a
hundred times faster than his opponents
and he also does not suffer from latency
or network interruptions this is what
makes the difference between a good
player and a champion
this is Freya she's an artist but also a
world-famous 3ds special effects
designer working from the comfort of her
home she works with film directors and
studios all over the world using
real-time cooperative design
applications and here is Ankur since she
retired from teaching she spends her
time conducting virtual visits of
international museums and teaching
children with learning disabilities all
this over the Internet
she also loves to Skype with her
daughter and grandchildren home sweet
home
meet Britt as you can tell she has a
creative mind her passion is to make
documentary movies she films just about
everything she sees with her little
camera and edits small clips that she
uploads on her blog and social media
every evening
and the beauty of this story is that
they can each do the online activities
they most enjoy doing all at the same
time and make no mistake this man is not
a hero he's just a fiber enabled super
citizen